So we have seen what a single
bit in memory looks like.
Now let's see how the whole
chip is organized.
We said already that we have these
word lines that activate cells.
We have a number of word lines, and
the thing that decides which word line
gets activated is called a row decoder.
What we give to the row decoder is
some bits of the address that tallied
which of the word lines to activate.
It can only activate one
word line at a time.
So this is a real decoder.
You give it a number.
It activates a line that
corresponds to that number.
In memory, we call this row address.
There is also a bit line here, and
if you remember, a memory cell
exists at every intersection between
this bit line and a word line.
So what a word line does
is it connects this cell,
this cell, this cell, or
this cell to the bit line.
So by supplying, let's say,
two bits of the address,
which was which of the four bits would
be outputting on this one bit line.
Of course,
there are more bit lines than just one.
And this, for example,
is a 16 bit memory.
It's a four-by-four bit memory.
Four bits can output to
the same bit line, and
there are four bits activated
by each of the word lines, so
when we select the row,
four bits get output out of here.
Now bit lines are very long.
And as we said, the cell is either
a relatively weak SRAM cell, so
it will slowly pull the bit line one way
or the other, or it is a DRAM cell that
discharges a relatively small capacitor
into this relatively long bit line.
If we discharge a small
capacitor into a long bit line,
the voltage on the bit line will change,
but it will change relatively little.
It will not change all the way to
the level that corresponds to a one or
to a zero.
If we have a weak cell,
we don't want to wait for
that cell to raise the whole
bit line one way or the other.
This is why the bit lines are connected
to a device called sense amplifier.
What it does is it senses the small
changes on the bit line and
amplifies them.
So it's really helping the cell raise or
lower the voltage on the bit line.
And it has relatively
powerful circuitry for
each bit line, so it's significantly
bigger than a single row of cells,
but you only need one of these
at the end of the bit line.
You don't need one of
these at every cell.
So you have relatively small and
weak cells, and you have this
beefy thing here that is helping
them raise or lower the bit line.
The signals that are produced by
the sense amplifier, which are now
correctly one or zero bits, go to
a storage element called row buffer.
The row buffer stores
the correct values that we read
from the whole row of cells.
So in this case, the row buffer will
contain four bits because that's how
many bits are there in the row.
The row buffer feeds the data it latched
to another decoder that is
called a column decoder.
This decoder selects the correct
bit among these four,
let's say, using the column address,
which is another part of the data
address, and it outputs a single bit.
If we want to build something that has
more than just one bit of data for
each location, we will replicate this.
So we will have, let's say,
two of these, give them the same row and
column address, and
now they output a two bit value.